how's it goin everyone it's Warren and
it's a new month which means it's time
for a new segment of Theory Thursdays
and it also means that it's time to pick
a winner for last month last month we
had four weekly winners for Theory
Thursday so in this video I'll replay
all of their theories so you can vote on
which one you think should win the
overall month and the monthly prize
there will be a poll at the end of this
video so you can vote on which one you
think should win the overall month and
be sure to stay tuned later on today for
February's first episode of Theory
Thursday okay so here's a replay of all
of last month's weekly winners Jiri
number two comes from you sir gleaming
dust the theory states that ant-man gets
sucked into a time vortex once he gets
out of the time vortex he goes to the
Avengers headquarters and finds out that
he's actually in the wrong time I agree
with this I definitely think that
ant-man is going to go into a time
vortex and come out in the wrong time
once he gets out and realizes that he's
in the wrong time he goes and finds Hank
Pym and Janet Van Dyne
to figure out how to travel through time
vortexes once he figures it out he goes
back to the present time and finds the
remaining Avengers from there using time
travel the Avengers will go back to the
Battle of New York and begin to change
the events of the past and Captain
America will come up with a plan to get
the mine stone from Loki this theory
makes a lot of sense ant-man is stuck in
the quantum room right now he obviously
has to get out somehow and it could be
through a time vortex after all they did
mention it in the post-credit scene of
ant-man and the wasp and it makes sense
to go back to the Battle of New York and
get the mind stone from Loki so that's
theory now four comes from Austin Green
he's 16 and lives in South Carolina and
this theory has a very interesting take
on Avengers endgame Austin states that
nebula and Tony are floating through
space and what if while they're floating
through space they run into Thanos
Thanos is on Titan too which probably
isn't too far from Titan one which is
where Tony and nebula are coming from so
they run into Thanos but Thanos has
already finished his job he balanced the
universe so he doesn't want to fight he
just wants to be left alone so he sends
them back to earth using the space stone
once they meet up with the rest of the
Avengers they begin to prepare a plan to
go against Thanos
but since the snap the universe is now
vulnerable and this is where the second
threat comes in the second threat
threatens the entire universe sothe Anas
goes to the Avengers but gauntlet is too
damaged to undo the snap but the time
stone still works so famous we'll go
back in time with the Avengers to stop
himself from doing the snap we do know
that a new threat is coming and we did
see at the end of infinity war that the
Gartland is damaged it's also really
expected that famous will somehow work
with the Avengers so you never know this
could happen
so that's theory number four theory
number three comes from samuel 15 years
old from puerto rico and his friend
Sebastian Samuel has a theory on how he
thinks Avengers in games going to go
down he says that the movie will start
off with Thanos on Titan 2 watching the
Sun Rise on a grateful universe it'll
then cut to the Avengers facility where
some of the Avengers such as rocket and
Rhodey will have left to go search for
some of the heroes that may have
survived the snap Steve and Natasha are
figuring things out while banner is
looking at the missing heroes we then
cut to ant-man who is stuck inside of
the quantum realm who gets out of the
quantum realm thanks to the help of one
of his aunts when he gets out he sees
the dust on the floor but ignores it and
gets in his van to go search for people
when he's driving he doesn't see anybody
and when he can't find anybody that he
knows he gets worried and goes to the
Avengers headquarters and that's where
we see the scene with him and the
Avengers in game trailer to explain to
Scott everything that happened and Scott
realizes that the ashes were from Hank
Janet and hope that he freaks out
wondering about his daughter and he
starts asking about all the other heroes
spider-man Wanda Bucky and ask where
Tony is we see Steve thinking about Tony
and it cuts to Tony and nebula on the
Benatar they've already tracked earth
but don't have enough fuel to get there
and Tony is about to die Tony finishes
his message to pepper and nebula asks
about pepper and they get to know each
other and then Captain Marvel shows up
and the two of them explain who they are
and what exactly happened with Thanos
then Captain Marvel being afraid of what
happened to Nick Fury pushes them to
earth to the Avengers facility The
Avengers reunite and Tony reunites with
pepper and then Captain Marvel starts
talking about time travel and how she
can do it then Scott remembers what
Janet said about the time vortexes in
the quantum realm Tony and Scott then
work
quantum realm suits to go inside of the
quantum realm to collect time loop
fragments they are successful and they
end up designing suits to use the time
loop fragments to be able to travel
through time they then talk about a plan
to go back in time and collect the
Infinity stones that way the Infinity
stones that Thanos has currently
disappeared then the Avengers break off
into separate missions ant-man Captain
America and Iron Man go back to 2012 and
get the mine stone from Loki's scepter
in the current time Natasha sees the
news and sees that people are dead in
the streets of Japan with arrows in
their backs she knows it's clinched so
she goes to Japan when she finds him she
says this isn't you I can help you we're
family
Clint finishes the conversation by
taking off his mask turns around and
says I don't have one then they go back
to the Avengers HQ Scott Steve and Tony
get back and Tony says he needs to go
back to get the tesseract and Thor says
that he'll go get the reality stone
Tony throws on a shield uniform and goes
back to 2012 and gets the tesseract Thor
goes back in time to where he kills
Malekith and gets the reality stone but
he also sees himself from the past gives
himself a little chuckle and takes meal
near from him Thor then returns with the
reality stone storm breaker and mule
near Thor then remembers when he met dr.
strange so he goes back in time to talk
to him Doctor Strange realizes that the
fate of the universe depends on him
giving the time stone to Thor so he
gives it to him Thor thing goes to net a
Valier but doesn't find Eitri but he
does take the Infinity Gauntlet
prototype he comes back and gives it to
Tony and Tony makes a new suit called
the Infinity suit Natasha and Clint come
back and Clint talks to Captain Marvel
about the scrolls nebula then says that
she can go back in time and get the
Power Stone so she goes back in time and
takes it from Gamora and quill
she gets back and she explains the soul
stone to the Avengers and the Avengers
decide that they will not sacrifice
another life to retrieve it but they
have five stones and prepare for battle
they go back in time to where Wanda
blows up the mine stone and right when
Thanos is about to reverse time the
Avengers show up Dennis is confused so
he uses the space stone to teleport but
Tony uses the
Stone to read his mind so they quickly
follow Thanos to his planet they're
famous has prepared an army with the
reality stone and has used the soul
stone to bring back to Black Order the
Avengers fight in Captain America ends
up using mule near the Avengers end up
defeating Thanos and they use the stones
to undo the snap and destroy the stolen
stones and ven Tony and Steve rest
watching the Sun Rise on a grateful
universe so that's how Avengers endgame
could go down from Samuel and I think
there are a lot of elements in this
theory that could actually happen in the
movie specifically the Avengers going
back in time to collect the Infinity
stones and Tony start designing an
infinity suit
so that's theory number three theory
number three comes from Gotham Ramesh
from Melbourne Australia with a theory
on how the beginning of Avengers in-game
will happen
Gotham says it begins with Thanos on his
farm in Titan two peacefully and with
pride because he achieved his goal of
balancing the universe little did he
think of what the remaining superheroes
would do the remaining Avengers leave
will conduct to the Avengers facility to
find out how big of an impact the
decimation caused when they get there
Pepper Potts is already there waiting to
show them a message from Tony this is
the same one he recorded in the Avengers
in-game trailer rocket figures out that
Tony is on the benitar and finds a way
to track it down meanwhile Captain
Marvel returns to earth and tries to
find fury and goes to the road where
fury activated the pager from the end
credits scene of Infinity Ward then she
goes to the hidden shield facility and
finds Klein who was mentioned in the end
credits scenes of infinity war as well
he takes Captain Marvel to the Avengers
facility there everybody's busy trying
to find a way to get Tony back and
trying to find out who else has gone
missing banner when he is trying to
check the missing people's lists tries
to connect with the Hulk and resolve
their issues Thor tries to find dr.
Selvig when he does find him he is
mortified of what happened and Thor
takes him to the facility and they start
discussing what happened
Natasha explains to Captain Marvel about
what Thanos did meanwhile rocket tells
Rhodey that he found a way to track down
the Benatar pepper insists that she
wants to go with rocket and at that time
road he gives her a bracelet that Tony
wanted to give her which is the same
bracelet from the first Avengers movie
which Tony uses to put on his suit but
this time it's the rescue suit she puts
on the suit and then her Rhodey and
rocket go into space to get Tony and
nebula
and Captain Marvel joins as well in the
meantime cap is trying to find clues
from shield files and archive videos to
find more agents to get ready for a war
and then he comes across a video of
ant-man and shows it to Thor
banner and Selvig to get answers when
Tony gets back he looks quite old due to
starvation and he finds out that time
travel is possible thanks to ant man's
video he then tells banner about barf
Tech and they try to find a way to reach
ant-man
Tony then asked banner to contact Wong
and asked Wang to find a way to
communicate with dr. strange to find out
the outcome of what they're about to do
Wong ultimately says no because having
that knowledge of the future is too
dangerous and that does it for Gotham's
theory there is definitely a lot from
this theory that could happen in
Avengers endgame a couple things that
Gotham mentioned that not a lot of
people really think about our selves
aghh and climb we actually know that
Selvig survived the snap we know this
from the book Thanos
Titan consumed which ties directly into
the MCU so he'll probably have a role in
Avengers in game client is also
speculated to have a pretty decent role
he's mentioned in the post credits scene
for Avengers infinity war and mentioned
in the Captain Marvel prelude comic and
I definitely think that he's going to be
the one to introduce Captain Marvel to
the rest of the Avengers and I do think
that in some way Wong will figure out
how to communicate with Doctor Strange
so that does it for theory number 3 on
okay that's it for last month's weekly
winners be sure to vote on which one you
think should win the overall month and
monthly prize and again be sure to tune
in later on today for this month's first
episode of Theory Thursday as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]